Now early versions of HTTP, actually only had
one request or response for every TCP connection. On
the plus side, this is simple to implement.
But the main drawback is that is requires a
TCP connection, for every request. Thereby introducing a
lot of overhead and slowing transfer. First of all
we need a TCP three-way handshake for every
request, and TCP must start in slow start every
time the connection opens. This is exacerbated
by the fact that short transfers are very
bad for TCP because TCP is always stuck in slow start and never gets a chance
to actually ramp up to steady state
transfer. Also, as TCP connections are terminated after
every request is completed, the servers have many
connections that are forced to keep TCP connections
in time-wait states until the timers expire, thus resulting in additional
resources that the server needs to keep reserved even after the
connections have completed. So a solution to increased efficiency and account
for many of these drawbacks is to use something called persistent connections.